where have you been where have you been
why are you showering straight away and
why are you so happy yes stop smiling
all the time because I know we're not
okay so she's just chopping carrots and
then you see a little like just smirk
she's just
[Music]
here's my number
so call me maybe
anyway boys girls you know what time it
is it's Monday fun day favorite day of
the week and you know how we start the
episode we like to go straight to the
juicy wussy Boosie
and the question of the week was
drumroll please
what was the moment you realized you
needed to get your life in order did you
think of that question fun facts no I
didn't someone said that to me a fan
sent it to me I think she said oh this
should this would be a good question and
I was like gang run it and I did it that
same day I was like wow thank you run it
back into me again
when was the moment you realized you
needed to get your life in order okay
say less and as per usual guys you
already know just it was sloppy top
juice and down your chin dripping down
everywhere neck drenched everything
everything drenched drenched brother
when I couldn't go to sleep without
stalking his IG first oh bro
you know what it's actually funny I was
doing reflection on my life the other
day and I was thinking in my life I felt
toxicity in my in my blood so have I
boiling blood fizzing yeah yeah like to
the point where it's just like the least
that's why I like
you would I when I was younger if I had
a photo now I would have to tell the
girl block me please
and they'd be like no you just oh you're
so empathetic just block me and I'm like
no no you don't understand you don't
understand you have to block me yeah you
literally have to block me because like
I'll just yeah for health and safety
reasons you need to block me yeah it's
uh it's it's Butters yeah you're a
health hazard it is Butters but that's
wow okay that is a realization moment
yeah when my brother reported my
boyfriend to the local authorities
Raw
yeah she was like raw literally she was
like oh this is what um raw this is what
I'm bringing to the yard right he's got
my life in order say less my brother
reported him to the local authorities so
he's a criminal he's nuts wherever he's
doing is nuts that's a man it's a man
she's just she's witnessing she's just
sitting back and being like her own
brother is like I don't care who I annoy
with this fat I don't care who I know he
is get him out of it because I can't be
part of this yeah yeah an accomplice nah
not me oh okay when I ran out of money
at the end of the month and couldn't
afford to buy one onion
foreign
Grossman Source wasn't on offer for a
pound
I didn't know what I was going to do
yeah yeah I literally didn't know what I
was gonna do Lloyd Grossman saved us um
I used to get the tomato spinach and
ricotta that's the one I used to get if
that one wasn't on offer for a pound I
was done and I used to make such a big
batch I just have to pour the sauce in
yeah and I couldn't afford the big sauce
yeah yeah I pour it in refill it shake
it yeah yeah every single Remnant bro
and then I'd even have to sometimes I'd
have to do a third Shake no you never
yeah so I don't know I didn't tell you
man about that one yeah clear water
clear water yeah I said that and I just
had to reduce and reduce oh God until
it's just lightly coated in the pasta
salt and pepper everywhere Jesus Christ
an extra spinach
worst months of my life and I remember
I've said this story a million times the
most frustrating thing for me was the
fact that I so our gym allowed us to pay
monthly or weekly yes yes yes month was
30 quid yes weekly was 10 pounds okay so
over the course of the month I'm paying
more but I never had a spare 30 quid so
I would always have to pay 10 pound a
week every Monday I'd have to pay 10
pound a week for this gym because I
never had enough money to pay for the
month yeah Future Fitness great job
Shout Out Future Fitness and Coventry
unbelievable gym yeah that's where the
journey started yeah it really was it
really was
um anyway back to it when you realized
uh when was the moment you realized you
had to get your life in order when I had
to use the empty toilet paper roll as
toilet paper because I'm a mess I've
done that before what the brown tea yeah
[Music]
this is a safe space right I've done
that before
in an emergency
as so my only Assumption of an emergency
is your night yard
um yeah I'm not a yard I don't have
access to a shower yeah I don't have
access to run down yeah with my like my
Caked Up batty I can't just run down the
stairs yeah so um yeah I didn't have the
opportunity to just run downstairs and
get it sorted
um so yeah I remember the roll was empty
it was already too late yeah I was
blocking yeah the roll had like one
piece of paper left on it and I was like
no no no no no no I did the initial wipe
ah you just stacked it yeah so much more
than this stashed it in there and I'm
I'm panicked looking around and I was
like oh I don't know what we're gonna do
and then obviously the little brown
thing so I literally just like got one
edge of the cylinder and just
and then cried
I would have did you unravel it nah
because I didn't want paper cuts I was
really concerned about paper cuts I
would be good and the unraveling it
won't it won't mold to your your body
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it would
just be flat I'll say you didn't so I
listed in the cylinder and then just
gave it yeah and then okay yeah I just
caressed it okay yeah
so yeah I had a little spiral thinker I
had a spiral dude
wild yeah yeah was there no sink in this
toilet was it just a toilet was there no
sink uh there was no sinking no no no no
no there was a sink but there was no
towel and there was no paper towels or
anything like that I remember actually
no there was a towel but I wasn't using
the towel okay there was a towel there
was a sink and a towel
um but I wasn't in a position where I
could like squat over and just wash this
because the water would have gone
everywhere Sailors oh
I think I would have rather done that I
would have take I would have backed up
my Crepes backed off my bottoms and just
sat in the sink and then yeah straight
for it that's what it does all right so
less
anyway back to it
realize I spent three hours online
gambling in my work bathroom and we
closed an hour ago
we closed an hour ago bro I hear
gamblins and addiction
you know my horror stories Bro you've
been you've been present at some of them
when I come when I'm in a casino
sometimes I become a different person
I'm so intrigued why because it's I hate
what is it losing even though I lose
more yeah yeah you know what I mean I
feel like I feel like I can with I
always feel like I can win the next one
always obviously that's the reason why
I'm there I always feel like I can win
the next one but I just sometimes I do
and sometimes I don't but when I do I
don't know I don't know my limits I
generally don't know my name is I could
give I could win let's say five bills on
time I'll say hold three no matter what
don't give me that three
[Laughter]
because it's my money regardless
I know what I told you five minutes ago
but it's my money regardless run me my
money you're not my back
oh not my bank
Harry I don't know where that started oh
neither do I um did you win the first
time you went casino this is all it was
always my question yeah um the first
time I went casino that I can recall is
in uni um
I don't know whether it was in actually
in actual car probably wearing brown but
it was all of us and Jay gave me money
to play I remember oh I think he gave me
like 20 pounds this uh this I tell you
where it was this was in Star City in
Birmingham yes
I remember I think all of us were there
yeah we were there all of us were there
I lost my money immediately Jay gave me
20 quid and I think I won maybe 100
something or 200 aside I felt caked yeah
and that's when it started yeah because
my first question anyone who has a
problem with gambling I was my question
always is did the first time you played
did you win because the first three
times I played I lost so there's I have
no love for this game yeah yeah every
time I've won since then it's always
been like I have no high yeah because
the first few times I went I went that
Jacob time
I've been before that with my friend
Jason and I was so broke I would only
ever be able to pay with like play with
like 10 pounds 20 pound like I didn't
have a spare 50 pounds so I would
immediately jump on that roulette table
and just be like um bang either on black
or red or whatever and my lights done
immediately first round done this job
and I'm like this is pointless yeah it
is it's literally because you feel like
if you go there with a hundred pound you
feel like okay I've come in with quite a
bit so I can't lose it that quickly oh
you can you can you can you can you
literally can by the time you spread out
10 pounds on a roulette save your
fingers that's done oh my God I won
nothing this right yeah I have to go
again I have to go again because now I'm
10 pound down
oh my God jar in anyway
when you cut when you can count more
one-night stands than relationships oh
well
that's about it I
I got Stan's brother
not like someone you're just having fun
with
you've got more one-night stands than
relationships I've probably got 10 times
more one less anxiety relationships
one night stands yeah people I don't
know their name
maybe I do need to get my life in order
because your reaction is not what I
expected your reaction's not really
expected that one night stands no I'm
not saying like you know exactly what
I'm not saying yeah so you're not saying
like a little linky thing yeah I've seen
him for a couple of years I've had a few
times she got my number that night I
don't remember her name
I rolled through she rolled through or
whatever or we went straight from the
shubs yeah yeah yeah and we didn't speak
again I'm talking about that say less I
can count I just I'm just on the top
just from just from the Dome yeah uh one
two three four five
six oh God
seven
eight oh God
let's stop let's stop let's stop let's
stop let's start eight yeah eight
wholesome let's say eight yeah yeah
yeah I can only remember one because I
got to six before I even remembered
abroad let's just say that oh yeah
definitely yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
definitely stopping here
the only one I remember which I can't
even call her one night stand because I
to people I don't remember her name and
I don't if I even knew her name then but
I knew she existed kind of thing I knew
she was that was the one I said I know
who you're talking about yeah that was
the one okay yeah that was one million
especially when you the next time you
saw her she didn't acknowledge you
existed facts next to me in the library
I was even gonna give a young spot yeah
like we had intercourse not too long ago
I was inside you and you're ignoring me
like this wait she didn't look at you
look at me I remember like it was
yesterday I was howling couldn't believe
I remember exactly where we were sat
okay but do you know the goat thing
about it she was way ahead of the game
than me oh
and then she didn't think about you
again like I was like wrong yeah yeah
nine I just thought of number nine
sorry sorry sorry
[Laughter]
man said
when I lost my job lost my girl and lost
my apartment in that order
job girl and then apartment in that
order did she keep the apartment or
landlord said get out I have no phone
this is a co-signed situation I didn't
ask any more questions oh my God I need
to sort my life out that would really
really really either apartment block on
the stairs sitting there just looking at
passengers go back and forth thinking
yeah yeah I lost everything I've lost
everything you're just looking at cars
go by thinking wow that's you and
Deloitte times
time lapse that's what
just what is it of like Will Smith in um
this thing you did the complete opposite
I couldn't believe it I
couldn't believe it
they sat ellite wow
from I'll have lunch go to the toilet
sleep for half an hour yeah
I hated that Jordan
bro I've had some jobs in my time man
that's so jokes
that sacked my eyes yeah they weren't
letting you get away with anything oh
they monitored the whole thing
oh God
for a month I went to school with the
same clothes from the night before
a month
the same okay I'll be talking the same
outfit or no no it just went out oh
every day for a month they went out and
then stayed out all night and went to
school oh my god that's way worse active
wow it was a boy God remember
can't remember jeez bro that's
disgusting active that's a different
level of activity
when I was taking a shower and barely
saw my feet when I looked down yeah
facts that'll wake you up quick quickly
quickly that will wake you up quickly
your stomach is massive and you're
thinking about it do I need to clip my
toenails or and you look down and you
can't see anyone can't even see it it's
just belly
safe no it's 100 yeah
because I want to jump bro so site needs
to happen yeah yeah
when I sprained my ankle shooting around
on an empty court
you know
I think you understand how much I'd
screaming that happened to me if I'm on
a empty basket the silence in your face
I was picturing it I might say
in the rain or something
and it snaps his ankle is on the floor
screaming
and you just look around and no one's
there to help you not a single soul get
a friend
literally find a friend oh yeah I would
think yeah I'm a Loser yeah I lose I
need to get my life in order I'm a loser
bro
snap my ankles no one even here nobody I
just crossed myself
literally double bell oh shameful
when I was paying for a man's Uber to go
to another girl's house
that's impossible
that is impossible
I need to get my life in order wow yeah
man no that's that's probably one of the
saddest things you've ever read on this
shows heinous paid oh I can't hear that
again painless brother well I can't I
literally can't repeat it
when I spent 1K on a man who I knew was
cheating on me
I knew he was cheating on me I spent a
bag on his Splurge because I loved him I
just went to city center and splurged
oh these are dark these are taking a
dark turn they were funny funny they've
taken an immediate doctor
when I told him I was done and he said
same time next week and he was right
there's no backbone
that's all I've heard three three
statements in a row all of her to
spineless spiders spiders
yeah yeah yeah yeah no self-efficacy now
whatsoever oh whatsoever babe I'm done
you know what yeah wife me
or leave bro that's what she said wife
me or delete my number a man said yeah
yeah same time next week same time
whatever whatever you're just chatting
the same time next week and she's
running she ran it back next week she
ran it back she's gonna help herself
when he got that message he rolled his
eyes yeah
rode his eyes are rolled through
whatever yeah it found this dumbass bro
I'm tired of this charade
when I realized my Visa dependent on my
marriage that just ended
scary scary she's thinking I could get
deported I will get deported we'll get
deported I can't let the authorities
find out oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no can you imagine
being comfortable in a in a country for
like 15 years no and it's all dependent
on your marriage no and you forget why
you're here bro you forget the reason
why when those divorce papers come
through you're like oh my god I've just
clocked
I forgive
stop stop stop stop
nah that's crazy
found this one's sweet in me when I
pretended to talk to my fake boyfriend
up the stairs when another huge takeaway
arrived
bro that's so funny I watched the Key
and Peele skit about that the other day
I swear where he's ordering pizza okay
uh and he's like oh we're gonna get uh
one large pizza like pepperoni pineapple
or this and he's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah and he's like uh and the guy's like
anything else and they and he's like oh
let me just check with the room any
business phone that's like guys you want
anything else is that yeah we're gonna
take another large pizza and then he's
like are you sure is that it he's like
let me just check guys one more time
last check anyone anyone want anything
he's like yeah we're taking on the large
pizza bro mad wow wow how can you finish
three pieces what's wrong with him or
some people are fat bro true true
something I can eat I've seen people eat
something I can eat yeah you know what
scares me is when like really really
overweight people like eat tiny little
mouthfuls
but they're just eat well they eat
proper sensibly where they can have the
whole table oh family the things just
over the course of half an hour the
thing's just gone that's Insanity yeah
it's mad
when I was rejected by both sexes
a woman wrote that by the way yeah of
course yeah nuts I was rejected by both
sexes I mean
sounds like she's just feeling sorry for
us yeah it sounds like you got rejected
by two people and now you've just
basically said the planet hates me
the
human race doesn't recognize me as a
sexual being
oh God
when I went to the same Club three
nights in a row and I bouncer said don't
you have a home to go to ah
don't you three nights in a row Runner
bro the same the same bouncer don't you
have a home to go to
I couldn't hear that I literally
couldn't hear that there was a girl I
went to college with I'm not gonna name
her but um
she was Notorious bro
just for a shoe bin okay I just would go
into one dirty Club in our town oh okay
like it was busted bro and she would go
there like Wednesday night Friday night
Saturday night Sunday night if it was
open oh wow and it'll just be constant
that was from when she was 16 because
she had someone else's idea that she
could use so 16 17 and 18 until we went
to UNI she was in there three four times
a week and his club's disgusting bro and
she will get murked and she would gain
more and more and more weight every week
and I was just like get it together I
didn't say this to her but I was
thinking really get it together first
thing that came to mind is probably she
I'm assuming she had troubles at home
maybe because I'm thinking like I think
uh
I don't know I feel as a Hop's given a
job I don't think she did that's just
because that's an acceptable behavior
bro
that's unacceptable Behavior three four
times a week for two years yeah yeah I
would abandon from the club oh so if it
was my spot I'm Banning you from the
club yeah I saw you find love though
literally go and find some love because
it's not making sense yeah it is grim
right uh when was the moment you
realized you need to scale your life in
order
when I ate a pack of two muffins and hid
the evidence
random this is random yeah
hang on
when I was a kid yeah oh this is so dumb
bro when I was a kid my mom used to make
us pack lunches okay and this is mad
because now everyone everyone who has
like you know when like kids have
preschool dinners yes all my boys had
preschool dinners I didn't my mom forced
me to have packed lunch she said what it
does to eat healthy okay I hated it I
hated it yeah I won't sound hot yeah I'd
freeze what it is yeah bro yeah yeah but
we we did we didn't qualify for free
school dinners
or I wasn't saying oh no you didn't
qualify for some reasonable dinners yeah
because my mom
yeah yes yes of course yeah I didn't
qualify so she would have had to pay for
them yeah yeah yeah yeah so
she's like I'm not paying for school
dinners you can have packed lunch I'm
like say less so I used to just get
scooters anyway obviously yeah I gotta
find it yeah I just buy it and then I
come home with my lunchbox just full of
the same [ __ ] and bear times I would
always tell myself throw it in the bin
on the way home I would forget fuhad
boys oh yeah there was a point where I
used to come home I knew I couldn't put
it in a bin yeah it's too big it's too
big so I used to put it under my bed and
I'm like the whole box or just a scrum
the scrum okay so there'd be a half
eaten sandwich in the sandwich bag
that's under the bed the Apple under the
bed yeah packet of Chris I know I always
use the back of my careers so I'd have
that's a lot of treats yeah there's a
little treat yeah yeah I'd have my hot
lunch my packet of course I'm a bit of
my sandwich yeah and I ain't eating his
apple and I ain't eating the rest is
dirty ham sandwich yeah so I used to
dash that under my bed that's the Apple
under bed fam I need to tell myself take
it to school tomorrow yeah throw it in a
bin on the way home yeah I forget bro
and it's actually how much I forget now
is actually not even surprising when I
think back about that I used to forget
on a daily basis
to the point where I looked under my bed
yeah and this is what my like I need to
get my life in order yeah yeah yeah I
looked under my bed and there was rotten
apples and rotten sandwiches everywhere
everywhere and I was like I don't know
what I'm gonna do
it's stunk under there oh god oh I was
literally like I don't know what I'm
gonna do bro like his life yeah it would
have been life or death bro if my mum
went under there and saw
six months ago rotten sandwiches apples
she she would have murdered yeah she
said who's feeding you
who's feeding you because it's not me
yeah her first question would have been
like
so you hate money is what you're telling
me you love burning money I'm just
wasting money on you every day because
if you want to starve you can start bet
if you want to starve your stuff
fam it was Pig
literally I remember just getting the
old Tesco back shoving it in there and
just running out the door I couldn't let
her see me yeah right out the door and
found the closest bin oh man God that's
jokes that's jokes
when my girl said I had an hourglass
figure
no but
an hourglass figure my girl said you're
one of these drones you're looking yeah
yeah that hip to waist is is looking in
and out
wow he's got my life in order and he
said hit the shredders I need to do
something you've got an hourglass
that's that's a switch
oh
when I had to add up the when I had to
add up the five items in my basket
before I got to the till in Audi I've
done that before not an Audi but I've
done that I've done a bear time the
mental maths I'm doing when I'm in the
queue I used to do it I used to have to
do a Roundup thing oh yeah yeah yeah
because 59p is a power it's a pound
right yeah if it cost three particles
four pounds and then by the end of it if
I know I've got enough then we can pay
for it yeah yeah I'll be sweating when
they used to go through the thing but
when it's scanning figure oh my God oh
my God yeah I feel like this is more
than what I could it's more what am I
bargain for fam because you've done the
math yeah yeah yeah you've got ten
thousand across seven you've done the
maths bro and you see you've got three
more things and it's on six pounds
already
and then the deal of the day better go
through it has to go through that club
car prices to go through because I'm
banking on it because this is all I've
got
and I'm also too embarrassed to say I'm
pretty sure that's on offer oh I can't
even say that I I cringe when I see
people like uh I swear down like you're
charging me 79p it's supposed to be 69
pieces you're like bro just paid it to
50. yeah please please just pay it
oh god oh I've been there wow this is a
deep one you know
when boss man in the corner shop started
making comments about how much wine I
would buy
um
[Music]
this one this one used to be me bro when
I couldn't touch my toes
I remember there was a point in uni you
remember doing up stretches yeah I
couldn't touch my toes brother I was
like what's wrong with me what's wrong
with me bro oh I wasn't flexible it's
not even flexibility yeah
touch and Toes is like base level
flexibility
base level Mobility I couldn't do it I
think there's something wrong with me I
need to get my life in order facts
because I can't even touch my toes I'm
nice now obviously yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah stay tuned
years
[Laughter]
wow oh days
when someone called me the fat sister
tough
eight three day old wings from Dixie's
no you didn't
yes he did that will turn your stomach
inside outside out the bone collar would
look different on that
wow three day old Dixies yes different
brother different
yeah
when my six-year-old son started telling
random people my mum's single
ah your mum just can't chirps anyone
yeah my mom's single I'm single are you
interested mum I'm single
that's so humiliated that's all he hears
is her on the phone saying why can't I
get a man why can't I keep a man that's
all he hears what is he's talking to
again I can't keep a man Superman to
save my life I'm so single it's
disgusting he said he's going to text me
back he hasn't oh he said he was going
to text me back and he hasn't
it's tough oh my mom's single my mom
apparently my mom's singing I'm single
they were up yeah they were up she's
singles humiliated and last but not
least when I was selling my kitty on oaf
for the same prices as Tesco meal deals
that's what when you put things into
perspective like that right 3.99 for
this TomTom 399 or 350 even for this
this is my worth this is my worth a
Tesco oh no and man is still hesitant
man let's do it that's mad to me no
one's got a nebula bargain no one said
that
[ __ ]
yeah 350 a month
I don't think so
it was good in here like bargain that's
the bar in the day
bro talk to me ask me a question I'm
gonna tell you what to ask me then ask
me the question say less say James who
do I go to if I want a clean and perfect
pretty little package James manscaped is
the answer bro
[Laughter]
wow never cut me off like that
manscapes is an answer manscapes has
always been the answer guys and by now
you should know the drill guys manscape
is a One-Stop shop for all your holiday
needs they got the perfect gift in the
Platinum package Platinum package 4.0
plus loads of little presents perfect
for your stocking stuffers guys come on
that was so much alliteration nailed it
nailed it one take Drake come on um so
guys you already know what you need to
do we've been through this before we're
gonna go for it again head on over to
manscaped.com the code that you want to
type in is s n g Sierra November comma
Now and you might be wondering guys why
would I put in that code because guys
that code is going to give you 20 off
plus the shipping is free you know how
these men like to dilly dally were
shipping these days cost an arm and a
leg these men put in this code that is
unique to this show unique listeners and
viewers of this show put in the code 20
off free shipping worldwide
doitnowscape.com and now we're gonna get
back to the show yes sir but yeah that
was the question today that was biking
oh yeah all right guys welcome back
welcome back welcome back this is
episode 241 of your favorite show shits
and gigs second best podcast on the
planet uh so much thank you for all the
love the spy for a rap love all this
stuff that's happened over the last uh
week or so it's been Sensational got
loads of lovely feedback from everyone
you did
um for last week's episode uh about like
getting deeper and talking about like uh
insecurities using my frustrations and
like self reflection and all that stuff
so yeah thank you guys for all those DMS
appreciate
um
so guys what you need to do right now if
you want to enjoy more of our content
moving forward is you need to go on over
to patreon.com forward slash shits and
gigs and that is gonna cost you a very
very very humble bargain bargain bargain
actual bargain actually three pound a
month 10p a day run the pizza s g guys
that's what you need to do and become a
true member of the cult babies cult
babies where you called daddies and just
embrace the culture that's what you need
to do
patreon.comgigs head on over there now
and as well guys as always if you're
watching us on YouTube thank you so much
for watching us on YouTube please
subscribe to the Channel please ring the
notification Bell if you're listening to
us on any of your podcasts and apps guys
um leave a nice review I beg you always
leave a nice review five stars as
preferable whatever you say please say
it with chests okay without any further
Ado what we're going to do is move on
forward to my homie Fire Lord Flags
um toe touching Tucci they call him
in lewisham
Southeast that's what they're cool man
he's gonna hit us with some knowledge
what's going on in the world today bro
so married couple divorced after
discovering that they were having an
affair with each other online using fake
names I knew you were gonna bring this
one up I knew this is a mad one I had to
brother in 2007 a Bosnian a Bosnian
couple divorced after discovering both
had an affair with each other using fake
names sarna 27 and Adam 32 from Bosnia
hadn't had marital issues so they were
secretly chatting and have an affair
online
after time they both discovered they
both decided to meet in person only to
find out it was each other
after a lengthy argument the couple
filed for divorce after being unfaithful
in quotes I thought I found the love of
my life
the way this Prince of Joyce spoke to me
the things he wrote the tenderness in
every expression was something I had
never had in my marriage
the Mad thing about that is why did I
only get her side of the story why did
it really get her her you know what fam
you know exactly why you know exactly
Chuck it in because men are trash no
one's even acknowledging that she was in
there as well and you know what's
actually mad to me as well I was like
I'm surprised they got divorced from
this surely like this is the literally
same as the ID question this is when you
realize like you need to sort your life
out both of you man need to sort your
life out right and clearly you manner in
life yeah you're made for each other
clearly happened twice twice twice it's
happened twice twice you fell in love 17
years ago and you fall in love again
have you decided to meet up and you
thought and then your first thought is
like wow you're a g that's how you know
it's a toxic relationship both of them
are like wow wow do you know the
remember the Spider-Man thing the mean
the Spider-Man yeah yeah that's their
man wow you're a chief wow you're a
cheat and ever while you're a cheat say
less divorce divorce thing bro we love
each other we actually love each other
more than anyone loves anyone let's fix
this let's fix it all she said since
when are you into that since
oh yes
when you when you said that to me I was
thinking oh speaking this girl's a free
he's a freak and I we need to meet yeah
you have to be I went to risk of
automate this thing I
think and it's my it's my wife she's
literally next door first of all shame
on you you're a mother the first of all
shame on you you're a mother let's fix
that of two after that gang let's go
facts yeah facts show me all of that
because this isn't adding up
unless they were
it was what unless it was one of them
ones where they were doing up like
certain aliases and just gas in online
chatting purp like yo I'm gonna do this
this and this I like this this and that
neither of them like anything they're
just trying to smash yeah bro they're
just Bland this day yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah just so yeah unless they know
each other so well that when they saw
they was like oh it's all gas oh it was
actually your gas it was actually August
because I know that's not what you're
into I know you can't do that and I know
you won't do that yeah yeah so you're a
liar oh you were gonna let me eat your
ass you're a little liar yeah no you
were not because I know you don't mean
you won't even let me touch about it
yeah yeah you're a manipulator is what
you did you actually manipulated a poor
little girl that you never met into bed
saying you were gonna let her eat your
ass and you definitely weren't I know
you I don't that's why yeah
anyway but that one's wild wow that
wasn't really wild right I've got trash
news I'm very excited to tell oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
drum roll please and guys I literally
received three gazillion uh messages
about this so yesterday last couple days
your boy called it your boy actually
called it spot me on that you did I
called it bro I don't know if it was
patreon on YouTube but you did call it I
called it bro the liver King is on gear
yeah he's said it from time yeah he's
been lying to everyone yeah he's a con
artist yeah he is a kind of ice Rags
um so actually let me find the actual
thingy majiggy so
liver King allegedly spends over 10
grand a month on steroids as exposed in
a leaked email bro a month a month
that's a healthy amount to be uh
spinning on a month so
basically it's a leaked email from what
I can assume is his actual email address
um
and basically it's him emailing a dude
uh ask it basically giving them a
breakdown saying
um
this is my brand I've been working out
for I think it says I've been working
out for 35 years I know how to eat I
know how to train I know how to recover
um I'm in my mid-40s and it's getting
harder I've got this back fat uh and
I've been doing this is and he says I've
been doing these drugs nothing's
happening
um
and yeah he said literally this is what
I'm currently taking and it's bear stuff
bro bear stuff I don't even know about
is it this is the email Isn't it this is
the email see I the thing is I I got
sent that as well but I intentionally
didn't even bother reading into it
because I knew you were going to and I
knew they would send it to you as well
yeah yeah yeah I saw the email I was
thinking
as plausible as this is the email just
doesn't look
HD enough for me to believe
because it looks like it was photocopied
like in what day and age are we
trying to expose someone and
that's the only receipt they have it
like the way it looks it looks so
pixelated you know in my head I assumed
it was someone taking a picture of it
even still brother
it is a bit pixelated but I don't know
that was my only like well the thing is
the pixelation in my head the pixelation
isn't necessarily
like because if it was photoshopped yeah
the pixelation bits would only be the
important bits which would be his email
address so if it wasn't him you could
easily still get a normal email and that
wouldn't be pixelated because you would
have typed that if I was trying to troll
liver King yeah yeah the only bit that
would be photoshopped would be the email
the same is literally from Brian Johnson
and the date and all this stuff that
would be photoshopped but the rest of
this typing would be my typing that
wouldn't be cleared at all
um so but same thing I don't know
um
plus maybe it's even just this as
pixelated because
um like even the zoomed in version here
is less pixelated than this yeah this
main thing yeah yeah so maybe this has
just been rendered a thousand times
maybe this is on puberty I don't know
how many yeah
fair enough fair enough
um but yeah I didn't read it at all
because I just knew so yeah Basics him
giving a breakdown like this is my brand
this is who I am it's how long I've been
working out for
um and yeah man help me help me because
I need to look the part so do you think
now all of these sponsors and stuff are
just going to drop in well he doesn't
have any sponsors ah he Chris but um so
he's he basically for people who don't
know who the liver King is liver King is
a guy who has uh supplement businesses
and some other businesses all based
around his like Primal lifestyle Primal
eating so it's called the liver King
because he eats like so much like raw
liver uh testicles heart innards all
these things and he's basically just
like he says he basically lives his life
on these like nine ancestral tenants
they calls it and it's all about like
getting sunlight sleep uh the way you
eat and exercise and all this stuff and
he's like you need to eat like this you
need to sleep like this you need to be
doing all these Primal things if you
want to look like me if you want to like
live the best of your abilities and all
that stuff and he's gone on like all the
biggest podcasts in the world and spoke
about it spoke about it spoke around
every single time they'll be like yeah
yeah are you on gear and he'll be like
no he's flat out says no I am not no I
am not and he says and then he went on
One show and was like you know what I
actually might just start taking gear if
you might want to see what I look like
on gear I'm going to start taking some
gear and everyone's like all right say
less and what we spoke about before is
like it's such a good marketing scheme
Because unless someone has categorical
evidence that is on gear no one's going
to be willing to eat enough Raw Liver to
even test and live like him yeah to test
if this is actually what you can do and
what you can look like it's just not no
one's gonna do it but how have they not
caught him sooner because he's getting
it from somewhere yeah so basically he's
going to be getting it from the guy who
gives it to him so as long as he's
paying him like he said he's paying him
like this guy like 10 grand a month so
if he's paying this guy 10 grand a month
this guy has no incentive to bait him
out if someone's paying you 10 to 10
grand a month yeah and you see him
online I'm not I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna get what are you gonna do true you
might you might bet him out for an extra
payment of 10 grand 20 grand but there's
no longevity in that yeah you're you're
only 10 bags a month from this guy yeah
you're not gonna say nothing fair enough
um but I'm assuming so I
yes it got out somehow
um so yeah I don't know if it was
someone going through liver King's like
database if he was cleaning his I.T
security or whatever and thought Oh gear
or if it was this actual guy oh yeah
yeah yeah
um I don't know who leaked it but yeah
yeah he got Out Boy and I think it's as
well something like that's always going
to get out he's so clearly on steroids
of course and I think it's a lot of
people always like oh no no no he could
be in like this like percentage of LA
and he's like he lives like this way
like you never know and you're like I do
know bro I've spent enough time around
bodybuilders yeah to know what someone
in their mid-40s looks like when they
are again when they're not here Rags
I've been around long enough yeah yeah
I've seen enough physiques in my life
um
I've seen enough physics in my life to
see like what people look like and the
way he looks like
he looks dry all the time yeah yeah
crispy stage ready dry
all the time every day he never gains
any weight he's always looked pumped bro
he goes up to Palms are like bricks yeah
yeah he always looks super hard so he's
definitely taking stuff that like yeah
okay uh sorry sorry sorry sorry he just
looks so veiny and hard do you know what
I mean
yeah yeah
anyway
um
so yeah he's like he's he's obviously
taking stuff like hardening stuff like
um
uh I'm pretty sure REM
y does that Harden you up or just dries
you out
when you're hurting you up yeah
winstrol's on that list okay
um
which concerns me because WinStar was
short term right that's like back end of
your car last few weeks yeah yeah if
he's taking that for a long period of
time yeah so Windstar is like what
bodybuilders take like the last few
weeks of their cycle typically okay
really dries you out Chris you up and
hardens you up okay
um and
he looks like that all the time so if
he's taking and winstro was on the list
he says on the email I've only been
taking it for three weeks but I don't
know this was from 2021 that his email
was sent raw okay I didn't even see the
date yeah 2021 so if he's been on
Winstrol for a year I'll be concerned
um but yeah a lot of other stuff on
there I don't really know servers like
that a lot of stuff in there I don't
even recognize
um but yeah man
I'm guessed because he's a fraud
um I'm just thinking there must be
adverse side effects surely oh 100 but
he makes 100 million a year he's
definitely in a position where he can
afford the treatment necessary to keep
this going
he makes 100 million a year bro wow yeah
his business is he makes a hundred mil a
year fair enough yeah yeah so he had
every incentive to lie factual uh
because everyone knows for a fact like
if he just came out from the start and
was like this is how you should live
your life and someone was like are you
gonna get it he was like oh yeah I'm on
gear they would have been like
just chat it even though that's
obviously not true I know not just
taking steroids doesn't make you look
like that he looks insane yeah so like
has to work yeah yeah he still works his
ass off if you just sit at homesteaking
so I was not doing anything you won't
look any different yeah he still works
it's awesome so I'm not trying to take
anything away from that but you to have
a monetary incentive to lie to people on
a global scale like that and be asked to
your face a hundred times is this what
you're doing because you do realize if
you are doing this what you're actually
like you're you're a liar yeah yeah and
he's like I'm not doing it so it's calm
um so that's crazy but he's got enough
money in the bank right now where it
probably doesn't matter it doesn't
matter anymore um but now yeah he's been
clocked and that's uh
it was always going to come out at some
point you can't be that famous and say
so profusely all the time I'm not gay
I'm not among you without someone being
like say less I'm gonna find out I'm
gonna find out yeah yeah yeah so that
was fascinating uh you said you've got
trash news as well right yeah I do let
me just find it right this is more of
like a this is more of a scenario all
right
I cheated on my wife three years ago she
agreed to forgive me if we opened the
marriage but now I live in agony every
day oh I bet that's that that's the head
oh I bet that's the heading so my wife
39 found out I 41 have been hooking up
with a woman I met online who lived two
hours away
when the woman visited uh when the woman
visited we checked into a hotel this
went on for three months and we had met
a handful of times when my wife when my
wife eventually caught us she was
waiting in the lobby and saw us coming
down from the room oh she left me the
next day oh my God you my heart through
her he had fall down the stairs yeah
like there's a meme I think I can't
remember I think it's um Harry Harry is
it Harry Styles that's falling on the
stairs from um on like an award show or
something and security is trying to
catch oh wow wow
that'll be me that would be me concierge
if you're like what's going on yeah the
paramedics yeah I would cause so much of
a scene yeah the whole cheat inside will
be done I'd want to die immediately so
I'm not sure yeah when I'm riding down
the stairs I make sure the last step
as I'm flailing in there I need to have
enough spatial awareness so that last
step cracks my skull open because I
don't want to deal with this
I bet you wish he did that you wished he
did that oh
that's so funny
wow that's so funny
we separated for eight months and there
were terrible they were terrible on us
especially the children nine seven and
three
we started talking about getting back
together my wife thought since I was sex
life wasn't enough for me and that she
was sure I would cheat on her again we
might as well open the marriage I told
her no because I've learned my mistake
but she wouldn't wave up
I relented we decided in Brackets she
decided not to tell each other when
where and with whom
good rules facts in necessary essential
rules yeah yeah now over two years later
we are back to normal on the outside on
the inside I'm dying a little each day
every time I see her happy I wonder if
this is just her old bubbly self or if
she's thinking of someone else she's
very beautiful she's a very beautiful
woman and I'm sure she has no problems
finding men when she wants
whenever she takes a shower after coming
home from work whenever she rejects my
advances I think that she has been with
someone else and that kills me oh bro I
have tried to discuss clothes in the
marriage again but she shuts these
attempts down very quickly with the
divorce card
but before all this happened we were
having amazing sex several times a week
but now we have probably done it four to
five times in the past three years oh
she demands I use protection and she
refuses to let me eat her out or make
her come in any way I stopped asking
because the sex was painfully bad now I
haven't slept with anybody because the
look on my wife's face in that Lobby
still makes me sick with guilt I don't
know how much more I can take I love my
wife and I want to spend the rest of my
life with her will she ever stop
punishing me have you have you ever
forgiven a cheating spouse and stopped
punishing them what's going on in her
head oh wow I've never felt something so
like real in my life that's wow you
thought you were there in it
every fam he hit the nail on the head
bro every time she comes in from work
has a shower where have you been where
have you been why are you showering
straight away and why are you so happy
yes stop smiling all the time because I
know we're not okay so she's just
chopping carrots and then you see a
little like just smirk she's just you
don't even know front I'll drag your
hair what's so funny
I love my wife I want to be with her
forever forever
the sex is bad bro we don't bang and
she's just gassed all the time always
gassed she never lets me eat her out
never lets me eat her out and she never
lets me make her come oh never oh my God
we've had sex four to five times in
three years oh my God he's never
regretted something so much oh one
million I promise you I'm leaving her
bro he's gonna I'm leaving her through
her yeah I'm leaving her
he's tried to close the market a few
times she said yeah yeah let's get
divorced then let's get divorced then if
you want to close it let's lock it close
it because let's lock it because you
cheated on me remember yeah remember
remember why we're in this situation
remember what happened when I saw you in
that Lobby it's been three years I can't
do this I remember the smile in your
face
before you clocked me you were hand in
hand with this bro at least I had the
courtesy to take a shower after work
facts facts
and I thought something was fishy so I
followed you one day now look where we
are oh God no best believe I'm taking a
shower when I get back home they dare
touch me oh don't you dare touch me
don't you dare touch me
[Applause]
about close the marriage then
no but I said don't you dare you dare
touch me
sucks facts I feel like I'm her fats
are you there it's mad to me bro because
the maddest thing what he was saying
this story like when it was getting
towards the tail end of it he was saying
it as if he was the one that got cheated
on like he felt it was crazy how he was
like I love my wife it's been this it
felt like as if she cheated on him bro
he can't he can't handle it he literally
can't handle it he said it's a few
episodes he said that time ago bro man
them can't handle stuff like that every
night she's out I promise you I'll be
wrapped around the toilet
the kids Daddy was wrong don't ask me
questions bro every time she leaves this
yard for work friends this that the
other she doesn't even tell me what she
doesn't she's not a marriage I want to
be here tell me where she's going I just
cheated from I just hear Keys jingle and
doors close bro like here
for my no I can't actually I can't I
literally can't listen to this anymore
my heart rate is racing right she opens
the door he runs in the hallway just to
see who he is
she's smiling on her face smiling bro
it's like how was your day how was your
day great yours
great let's have a fist fight great it's
8 P.M I'll be sniffing I'll be fam INE
show me your underwear she goes I'm
looking through her bag yeah and she he
said in there she always makes him use
protection always on her now because
she's just assuming he's happy he's not
done and he's gonna touch the soul in
years he just sits a home and cries he
sits at home and cries because he misses
what he had oh this is like they used to
bang yeah yeah this is the worst I
promise you this is the worst thing I've
heard
absolute Nightmare and he's clarifying
every fear I would have ever had about
having opener issue he's clarifying
every fit wow
worst thing I've heard don't you dare
touch me no no no because I couldn't be
pulled up like that yeah babe I'm sorry
of what I did but I don't want to do
this anymore I can't live I can't
breathe I can't eat I can't sleep like
I'm just losing weight
swear swear that's how you feel stop
that's how you you're sexually mad don't
chastise me anymore that's how you feel
how do you think I felt when I when I
caught you with that bimbo three years
ago this lady dark that's not fair she's
not a bimbo she's not a bimbo so that's
not even that's not even start the name
calling because you're better than that
first of all you're better is that what
you're doing is that what you're doing
is that what you're carry on I'm not
even trying to cut you off carry on not
what you're doing carry on you're better
than that I carry on I will carry on
yeah going up soon anyway don't you
worry on then wait till challenge carry
on
you're the one get angry I'm I am
getting angry because I love you broth
you should have you should have thought
of that three years ago
years ago
that's all after do you actually even
love me this is actually mad no no no no
no no no no no the thing is I dare you
to say I did no no okay Google I was
gonna say I obviously did love okay let
me finish my sentence because all of
this attitude is pointing to the wrong
direction you should look at yourself
first and foremost
breaking Furniture okay that's your
problem that's your problem because you
bought that anyway I don't even want
that right listen listen to me now do
you want to be with me finish
I have love for you am I am I in love
with you do I want to go hand in hand on
road with you not anymore no get out
let's leave it then let's leave it
because you're you're making me suffer
because you said you have love for me if
you're having kids yeah you can use
suffer hang on hang on hang on actually
you're nice and cute oh okay you know
yeah I'm tired no remember it's a nice
guy yeah yeah you want to talk cute you
want to talk cute big man I was out here
clapping cheeks and you were like oh I'm
gonna follow him I'm gonna follow him
and then we broke up you walked out who
chirps two eight months later who chops
who you want to talk cute who chose me
back into this yard this lying little
yard who chops you I mean Circle your
gums then because you were alone for
eight months and you couldn't handle it
okay which my daddy had to come home and
save you yeah and now you want to chat
about cute because I'm in love okay
our nine-year-old told me you sleep by
the toilet every night yeah I do because
I can't stand to to think about what
you're doing out there oh because you
won't look at me oh you won't look at me
well you weren't looking at me why would
I look I was looking at you even when I
was even when I was still out there
clapping cheeks I was giving you that
good good four or five times a week you
don't look a man anymore because you're
too busy choking tall okay too busy
running into the shower straight from
work you think I'm dumb bruv rightly so
I should you think I'm dumb bro right I
should start using a black light on you
as usual for your door filth look yeah
you can call me look yeah
look at yourself you're talking about
mirror this mirror that insecure it
yourself twist up head back who's been
grips in your head back who's doing
grips in your head back pure insecure
insecure insecure my phone's ringing
yeah oh I bet it is yeah yeah I bet it
is when you're done yeah and stuff oh
big man I've been done when you leave
take your bag
I will you will and the kids no I
promise you you're not I promise you
you're not we'll see I swear do you want
to take do you want to play this game
with me do you actually want to play
this game with me divorce or not go when
you're dating it it's not a date you
want to oh you want to take kids you
want to take kids because you're loving
running these streets so much take the
kids and see how many pipes you have
because you're not bringing them to my
kids yard I tell you that for a fact
who's that
the yard that I will be paying for for
you and my children to leave living if
you think that you're taking them no no
I've got my money swear that's gang
music to my ears take your money and my
kids
never record what you just said so when
we're talking maintenance you can't do
these crocodile tears that you've been
doing that's fine record one more time
you've got your own one I've got my own
money your own money so I don't need to
pay for your yard that's why no
you're a liar take the use do what you
need to do go rob on whoever you need to
Rob on to make yourself feel good you
skank yeah yes follow me names insecure
yeah yeah I'm insecure yeah I'm gonna
secure myself to a next thing tonight
bro yes but okay
I will fight you today brother
wow you're the worst bro
I can't handle it
that oh no no no no no no no no that
black and white board thing yes this
this handoff thing I swear that's
domestic autistic yeah yes insecure
Instagram
who makes me want to throw stuff oh God
I'm just gonna throw stuff oh that's
that is too toxic that's the worst thing
I've heard too toxic right to finish
you've got Fred for us no oh yeah
So This Thread obviously in spirit of
um Thanksgiving that happened a few
weeks ago there's always I think every
year they do it there's always threads
about
um Thanksgiving clapbacks oh okay yeah
so this is actually on Instagram by us
um pages of tweets okay so
um and what happened to Thanksgiving
clapbacks that was my favorite part of
Twitter
so Uncle you need to find a husband and
have some babies that degree ain't gonna
keep you warm me
all your wives have left you how are you
Walter
Raw
quotes I wasn't drinking at 18. reply
can't drink when you're pregnant
wow these are clap backs bro they don't
care
they've already they had one too many
shots
[Music]
[Applause]
the mouth starts running I ain't seen
you in mumps you ain't really family to
me anyway wow wow wow
aunt
how are you going to eat all that food
when you didn't even help cook Uncle
How You Gonna pack all that food and
sodas when you didn't even bring
anything
calm facts calm you didn't bring
anything calm them
when are you gonna find a man me when is
yours gonna admit he likes them
oh wow that will cut
her soul right how are they how are
these men not fighting at the dinner
table
because they're family yeah geez on you
need to hurry up and get some babies me
you need to hurry up and find the daddy
of yours
that's dark very dark them
why don't you why don't you ever talk
you come off so dry
me can't be dry than your mac and cheese
that's the one
that's the one that's the one that's the
one I know my aunties would start
launching plates
it was like launching place it can't be
driving your Mac and Cheese yeah dishes
will Flink uncle
your mom told me your grades are
struggling
me no more than your hairline oh I was
waiting for a hairline on this entire
thread oh bro
it's dread
uncle
why are you always late
cousin we're trying to be like your
child support payments
bloody hell wow bro how has these man
got the chest for this bro I can't speak
to my family no no no
I couldn't I couldn't like my doubles
slapped me across the table Yeah ASAP
come
yeah cousin you don't know how to host
and have Thanksgiving at my house next
year me so we're going to be eating out
of a PO Box I'm good
a PO Box man say you don't even have a
you don't even have a disclosed location
you don't have a pinpoint you'd have a
pin drop where do you live right I don't
even know PO box
you keep eating like that and you're
gonna get fat
I see you speak from existence
hmm
uncle
does your mom know you're out here
smoking me does your girlfriend know
you're out here cheating
Prada it makes me realize I don't have a
family like oh neither do I have it in a
family like this my family leave me
alone yeah I could I couldn't have a
family yeah yeah on
you're on your third plate already me
you're your third husband already
[Music]
sake you still a vegan
have you still got high blood pressure
boy these are all black families there's
not been a single white family has an
entire conversation
on
I see you're still living with your mum
me I see your husband still hasn't come
back home
that was the last one Jesus these are
clap backs boy yeah I couldn't I
struggled to laugh at some of those some
of these days are like you're talking to
you you're clearly talking to your enemy
yeah yeah this is not family enemy
you're talking to your enemy yeah yeah
you like your weight you came into this
Thanksgiving went ready to swear to
describe facts wow but yeah wow wow all
right come on man yeah um that was bang
it Joe's episode right guys so thank you
for today banging episode as always
um quick reminder if you want to see us
on Thursday patreon.com shits and gigs
three Panama Tempe a day run the pizza S
and G uh and as always guys love love
[Music]
good
[Music]